The idea of a join has its roots in SQL, a declarative database language.
If you're not familiar with databases or SQL, don't worry.
If you are however, hopefully you can make some connections to
previous concepts you are familiar with.
Joins emerged out of relational database theory as a way to
associate two different tables or spreadsheets.
Now to understand what a join is, imagine we have two tables.
Or in this case, you can think of them as CSVs or TSVs.
Wherein the first table, in this case, the employee table, each row represents
an employee's last name and a department ID which they are employed in.
So, in the case of the first row, employee Rafferty works in department 31,
Jones works in department 33, and so forth.
One thing to note is the value null here, which represents an empty value.
So let's just say that John doesn't work for any specific one department.
These tables are example tables from the Wikipedia article on joins,
which explains all of the concepts I'm going to go over in much more depth.
A join can be thought of as a union of two different tables combined in
someway such that they make sense.
Now, the most natural way to join these tables might be on the common column in
this case DepartmentID that they both have.
So to join these two tables, we would simply go down each row in the first, and
for that DepartmentID match it to the equivalent DepartmentID,
in the department table.
And we would do the same for every row.
One thing to notice is that two employees can be mapped to the same department,
in this case, both Jones and Heisenberg belong to department 33.
Or there could be no employees for
a given department, in this case department 35.
Or if an employee doesn't have a department, he can't get mapped to any